bonjour tony renucci et bonjour avoue
daniel guerreau merci à tous les deux
d'être en direct ce matin sur arte
france pour ce débat je vais commencer
par vous daniel quéro que pensez vous de
cette mesure qui risque de passer au
sénat et qui limiterait l'accès au
centre ville
ces zones à fortes exclusion comme nous
l'appelons nous risquent effectivement
d'entraîner un certain nombre de
difficultés voire sociale parce que on
est toujours en train d'exclure les gens
les plus modestes
et comme vous l'avez justement souligné
et encore 66% des français qui ne savent
pas ce que sow cnf peu mais là on va
arriver très vite par exemple cette
année avec l'exclusion des catégories
catégorie cadet suivante à 20% du parc
aujourd'hui l'année prochaine quand on
va passer aux catégories 3 on veut à 50%
du pat d'aujourd'hui et quand en 2024 on
va interdire à partir de la vignette 2
qui comprend les diesels on a 80 % du
parc pratiquement voyez un petit peu
l'étendue de la difficulté donc les gens
ne vont pas je dirais tolérer simple
qu'on aura pop a proposé finalement de
mode de solutions on ne pense qu'à punir
interdire taxes et s'en va également
proposer des solutions alors jeu
simplifié un tous les véhicules
antérieurs à 1997 ne pourront plus
circuler dans les centre-ville à partir
de 2025 en gros qu'en pensez vous tony
renucci évidemment pour vous c'est une
bonne mesure mais je pense que les et
des feux c'est une bonne mesure
parce que ça rentre aussi dans un plan
plus global qui agit sur notre mobilité
et je ne peux pas ni ce que dit monsieur
puisque le capteur
effectivement ça peut entraîner des
difficultés sociales puisque on remarque
que la part des véhicules concernés dans
les éditions qui va s'impliquer dans la
métropole du grand paris c'est vrai elle
peut avoir un impact plus important sur
l'éducation en 13 où il y a
au moyen du modèle pour changer de
véhicule donc en fait ils vont partir de
ce constat et voir ensuite comment est
ce qu'on peut améliorer le dispositif et
faire en sorte qu'elles permettent
d'accéder à la reconversion vers des
véhicules moins polluants ou des
alternatives comme des transports en
commun ou l'humilité douce oui justement
alors ce genre de dispositif personnes
n'ont pas pour l'instant alors ça
concerne quand même 7 français sur 10
qui vont être contraints de changer de
véhicule quand on voit déjà que la
hausse du prix du pétrole avaient mis
les jets les jaunes dans la rue daniel
guerreau est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
une mobilisation de même type
oui comme je vous le dis aujourd'hui 66
% des français ne savent pas encore en
quoi de quoi ses fesses et des feux mais
quand ils vont découvrir l'étendue des
dégâts
ça va faire mal d'autant plus que la zdf
que si vous regardez à 200 et quelques
villes en europe où ça a été mis en
place c'est pas la solution c'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga puisque même la dame
dit oui on a modélisé ça apporte un
certain nombre de résultats mais la
pollution elle se balade si sauf à
mettre un mur lui qui va jusqu'au ciel
autour de paris vous n'allez jamais à
empêcher la pollution d'arriver dans
paris d'ailleurs à tel point que en
novembre 2020 il y avait le profil mans
c'était plus pollués qu'en novembre je
mets 19 où il n'y avait pas de
confinement
regardez les chiffres ils ne sont
publiés d'envoyer ce n'est pas vraiment
la solution
ça permet quelques améliorations mais ce
n'est pas la solution je pense qu'il
faut travailler surtout effectivement
comme disait monsieur sur les nouvelles
technologies on est en train de le faire
je remue renouvellement du parc
on est en train de le faire d'ailleurs
grâce à leur dévouement le
renouvellement du parc on s'aperçoit
qu'on 20 ans la diviser par deux le nom
de particules fines en france vous voyez
tous on trouve des solutions
il faut aussi organiser comme disait
monsieur la complémentarité entre
différents modes de transport c'est moi
j'habite dans les yvelines
si je veux aller par exemple à rueil
malmaison l'objet de passer par paris de
prendre le métro de pointe le but ça
mettra deux heures alors qu'avec ma
voiture je mets une demi-heure et donc
on n'a pas trouvé des solutions donc
interdire sans proposer de solution et
c'est qu'ils m'ont simplement entraîné
beaucoup google ont tenu renucci n'êtes
pas d'accord sur les chiffres
en fait ça fait plusieurs médias que je
fais où je fais face à des représentants
de 40 mo bi liste et à chaque fois nous
ressortez les mêmes arguments qui sont
fous ce que vous dites sur les chiffres
de pollution c'est faux le premier
confinement a réduit les concentrations
de dioxyde d azote de 20 à 35% et les
particules ultrafines de 30% et je sais
très bien que le chiffre auquel vous
référer c'est les particules alors
effectivement on remarque elles l'ont
été réduites en concentration que de 7%
après le premier confinement mais parce
que il a eu un effet aussi de report du
fait
certes on utiliser moins la voiture mais
la voiture n'est pas le premier émetteur
de particules dont je tiens quand même à
préciser et de deux camps ont été plus
souvent chez nous et pendant plus
utiliser le chauffage il ya eu un effet
de compensation donc vous me donnez pas
les bons chiffres et à chaque fois c'est
les mêmes arguments qui sont répétés ses
formes ce qu'on remarque ce qu'on
remarque c'est que quand il y à une
baisse du trafic routier il y à une
baisse des concentrations de paulhan
notamment les particules ultra fines et
de dioxyde d'azoté voilà il faut bien
que ça soit très clair dans l'esprit des
gens et je voudrais aussi préciser
qu'aujourd'hui on va voir un pic d'ozone
l'ozone
ce n'est pas directement kainry par
notre activité c'est une combinaison de
polluants mais notamment les oxydes d
azote qui sont très largement émis par
les voitures diesel
donc ça montre bien que quand il ya un
fort trafic routier
il y à des phénomènes ou de pic de
pollution ou de fortes pollutions de la
perle
et deuxième chose parce que jusqu'à quel
point cette deuxième chose sur les
constructeurs automobiles puisque là
aussi à chaque fois j'entends à cet
argument salle progresser je dis pas le
contraire mais vous ne pouvez pas nier
aussi qu'il ya eu un phénomène de
tricherie des constructeurs automobiles
il ya eu des mises en examen récente par
la justice française renault peugeot
citroën volkswagen et parce que ils ont
triché ils ont voulu optimiser sur des
moteurs qui était truqué pour répondre
artificiellement à des normes contre la
pollution de l'air donc on peut
donner si on n'est pas sur le sujet dit
la tricherie ou pas nous les chiffres
que je vous donne ils ont été publiés
par airparif ils sont publiés dans
régulièrement donc c'est pas des
chiffres qui sont faux il faut pas
attribuer mais ce qui est curieux
d'ailleurs c'est que depuis la pandémie
les gens prennent encore plusieurs
automobiles parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres choix
est ce que vous voulez basculé il ya 4,1
millions de parisiens ou de français qui
sont dans le métro tous les jours est ce
que vous voulez en bâche père et encore
plus dans le métro où on sait il ya dix
fois plus de particules fines que dans
la rue vous voyez il faut trouver des
solutions c'est pas par led je dirais
l'idéologie on va arriver avec des les
problèmes du quotidien
il y en a qui sont dans la vraie vie et
d'autres qui sont dans l'idéologie les
gens qui sont dans la vraie vie
moi je veux des solutions pour aller au
boulot je voulais trouver où je veux des
solutions alternatives
autrement c'est pas possible je me
révolte que pensez vous d'un daniel
guerreau je reste avec vous sur un les
aides proposées par le gouvernement pour
renouveler justement changer de véhicule
12000 euros a priori ou un micro crédit
de 5000 euros pour les plus défavorisés
ça vous ça vous paraît bien c'est chou
condition de revenus ces suivant le type
de voiture faut déjà avoir fait
polytechnique pour les comprendre
donc je pense que c'est une c'est un
progrès mais ça va pas résoudre tous les
problèmes les problèmes de mobilité
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut faire
cette position dans le temps en offrant
des solutions et en r étant toujours de
punir de montrer du doigt et ce sont
toujours les gens modestes parce que les
gens qui ont de l'argent ils ont ils
peuvent avoir une voiture électrique qui
peuvent rouler avec des taxis peuvent
rouler avec des vtc
mais les gens modestes en plus les gens
ne peuvent pas avoir de voiture les gens
modestes il faut qu'ils partent en
vacances avec leur famille la voiture
électrique n'est pas une voiture
multi-usages encore aujourd'hui oui il
ya un tas de problèmes comme ça qui sont
des problèmes de la vie quotidienne de
la vraie vie et après on peut leur dire
ce qu'on veut aux gens mais je vais voir
ce qui chaque jour comment il doit vivre
comment il se perd se déplacer comme
s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont taxés qui sont
empêchés ça pas mal forcément sonner
renucci c'est vrai on se souvient même
le gouvernement qui avait proposé un
chèque pour pouvoir
avoir un véhicule électrique est ce que
ça vous paraît convenable cette aide
proposée par le gouvernement pour tenter
d'aider ces personnes qui ne peuvent pas
se permettre de changer de véhicule
mais toutes les aides financières qui
permettront d'aller vers une
reconversion vers des prix des véhicules
pardon qui sont moins polluants seront
les bienvenues et aujourd'hui c'est iman
avec le cumul des aides on peut aller
jusqu'à dix neuf mille euros un véhicule
neuf ou douze numéros pour un véhicule
d'occasion après avec monsieur la sécu
l'électrique alors parce que ça coûte
quand même relativement cher aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que je dis là où je
rejoins comme monsieur c'est que
maintenant la difficulté de cette
mijoter dispositif c'est qu'il faut
accompagner des usagers vers cette
reconversion
et ce n'est pas toujours suffisant quand
on a un reste à charge de plusieurs
numéros c'est vrai puis c'est compliqué
pour des catégories plus populaires et
je pense que sur ce avec deux sujets
vraiment à travailler
le premier c'est le reste à charge
comment est-ce qu'on travaille
finalement sur le reste à charge pour
les familles et peut-être que là
d'ailleurs il faudrait voir c'est de
quelle façon est ce qu'on peut essayer
de mensualiser le reste à charge parce
qu'il ressemble pas non plus gratuite
mais il faut qu'on accompagne donc
l'achat du véhicule on peut pas aller
c'est bien sûr d'être traîné que jean
deroi à sortir ce serait très compliqué
votre réaction daniel guerreau alors que
le gouvernement avait incités à adopter
des diesel on s'en souvient donc les
français doivent s'adapter à chaque fois
au revirement de des politiques
écologiques en vigueur
nous sommes d'accord qu'il faut lui
qu'il faut transformer le parc nous
sommes d'accord qu'il faut aller vers
plus de deux parcs propre mais tout ça
se fait dans le temps ça se fait pas des
mues par des mesures brutales
ça se fait en apportant d'abord des
solutions avons interdit on commence par
interdire et on vous dit après on va
peut-être apporter des solutions dont
comprenez bien que les gens qui sont
confrontés au quotidien ça peut pas
fonctionner donc je pense que là et les
sénateurs j'espère qu'ils vont améliorer
donner du temps on a tous envie de mieux
respirer puisque monsieur et ne respire
bien entendu
l'info faut pas non plus pénalisé
toujours les gens modestes on va même
aller jusqu à pénaliser les couches
moyennes la voyez avec ces mesures comme
ça donc c'est sûr que savard des
conséquences sociales extrêmement
important la mise en place de parking
aux abords de des grandes villes c'est
une mesure plutôt simple à mettre en
place pourquoi est ce que ce n'est pas
le cas tony renucci ça pourrait
permettre effectivement de déposer son
véhicule avant de rentrer dans les
centres villes non oui bien sûr que ce
serait une idée aussi utile après voilà
moi je ne suis pas à la place des
gouvernements qu'ils ont mais en même
temps ce qu'il faut c'est aime aussi
trouver un équilibre c'est à dire qu' il
faudrait pas eu ce soit une façon de
contourner ce qu'on essaye de faire en
tant de restrictions de circulation pour
les voitures les plus polluantes
c'est à dire celles à moteur thermique
et il faut écouter bien sûr promouvoir
des alternatives et je suis pas moi je
comprends bien ce que vous dites
tu ferais bien sûr que c'était pas
évident qu'aujourd'hui être sains et il
n'est pas encore suffisamment valorisée
connu que d'être amplifié oui ça risque
majeur qu'il se fait de façon
progressive et qui n'est pas une
nouvelle
on a eu 25 cesser demain
oui critère c'est depuis 2000 plaintes
et écrite ainsi depuis 2015 donc à la
fois on a des industriels comme elles
savent depuis dix ou quinze qui détend
aussi de s'adapter et c'est pour ça que
je parle des constructeurs t'oublie pas
ce qu'on nous dit toujours ce discours
qu en tout cas de la part d'autres
associations comme quoi il serait très
vertueux ils ont amélioré les choses
ce qui n'est pas faux mais il était au
courant des grandes et ensuite par
contre c'est vrai que il ya une vraie
difficulté au niveau de l'information
des usagers et vous avez raison sur les
actes et cela n'est pas suffisamment
connus donc il faut que les usagers
soient mieux informés et mieux
accompagner dans l'application de cette
mesure
on voit là ce sera le mot de la fin on
n'a plus le temps malheureusement merci
beaucoup en tout cas daniel guerreau et
merci à vous tenir l outil d'avoir vécu
en direct sur cette question qui
concerne beaucoup de français
sur cette nouvelle loi à venir pour 2025
l'imposition des f e dans certaines
villes de francs